i feel really happy i'm really enjoying
i haven't been sleeping very much you
know in the last couple of days but
you know it was for sure it was worth it
you know i just feel like i just did
something something unbelievable and
also it's very nice to to know that i
actually
made another history so
i really appreciate it for me this
tournament means a lot of first times
this is the first grand slam i actually
visit when i was younger
then this is the first grand slam when i
made my grand slam debut in singles then
this is the first grand slam when i when
we won uh doubles
with my partner and now winning the
singles
you know this place is very special and
i just can't wait to come back next year
i don't know what's what's gonna happen
i think it's gonna change maybe a lot of
things but
you know i just really don't plan to
change i just really wanna stay stay me
and you know i just love tennis i wanna
keep keep working keep going and
keep trying to improve every you know
every time i step on a court and
you know right now i feel i can be more
relaxed because i have
achieved almost everything i always
wanted so
now it's just time to you know just go
out there and
have fun on the court you talked a lot
about jana novotna and justin and how
these two champions in different ways
helped you to become a grand slam
champion too
this this time like a couple days ago
was the first time i actually met
justine and we met each other during uh
you know like a tv commentating and
stuff and
you know i was really i was shocked i
was really you know i just started to
get read and i was really surprised
actually seeing her and that she
actually knows my name and
she told me that she was commentating me
and she likes my tennis and i'm like
well i watched you when i was younger so
you know i i always loved your
one-handed backhand you know i always
left
the way you played so
it was really really something
interesting really something meaningful
to me
and also you know working with diana
having a chance to you know to meet her
to spend a lot of time with her
you know she she guided me a lot
when i was younger and i'm just really
happy that
i got a lot of strength from her and
then i can just use it right now and
that i just
used it in last last two weeks
you